g'day is an Abomination to the English
language and should be thrown out with
other terms like prolly no cap and
intersectionality
excellent is g'day an Abomination to the
English language oh no I have to do I
have to guess you have to guess I think
you might say yes
there's not but I don't know no I think
it's a delightful colloquialism okay I I
rather and when I think of all the other
examples some of which you cited there
but many others as well I I think the
day is far from our worst problem and
frankly these days if someone is
speaking the English language at all I'm
grateful I'll take what I can get you've
got even the conservatives here in
America are giving their state of the
union response in Spanish uh-huh I think
oh well this is there's very little to
unite Us in America in the broader
anglosphere I think it'd be nice to have
the same yeah basically you must have at
least a language but that's a good point
I've never heard that argument